Trascrizione: Kim Sambati
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Fare il navigatore?
No, non serve a nulla.
Ma a me è servito
avere un posto nel mondo.
La storia più bella,
la rotta più bella che ho percorso,
e che voglio raccontarvi oggi,
è proprio quella così
imprevedibile, incredibile
che ho vissuto fino a qui,
per cercare di esserlo.
Immagino che, quando vi hanno detto
che faccio il navigatore oceanico,
abbiate pensato: vabbè, quello è matto.
Un po' sono anche fiero di esserlo,
quindi non cerco di spiegarvi
che non lo sono.
Effettivamente, a 15 anni
invece ero un ragazzo normale.
Nel senso che c'era qualcosa
che mi interessava,
la vela e la fisica in particolare.
Relativamente -
non è che fossi un bambino prodigio,
però la vela mi era -
Mi ero innamorato durante un corso estivo,
quindi molto per caso.
Erano quelle due settimane l'anno
che rimangono nell'angolo del cervello,
e non se ne vanno più.
E la fisica invece mi piaceva,
la forza della praticità che aveva,
perché riusciva a spiegare
cose reali, tangibili,
che sono le cose che mi
interessano particolarmente.
Però aveva anche la forza
dell'universalità,
nel senso che cerca di spiegare cose
per sempre, e in più precisamente.
Quindi, insomma,
io al liceo comunque non sono
uno studente brillante.
Mi faccio bocciare in terza liceo,
perché non avevo voglia di fare granché.
Non avevo motivazioni
di fare granché, galleggiavo.
Fatto sta che, verso la fine del liceo,
come tutti i ragazzi ho mille dubbi.
I miei amici cercano
di risolvere questi dubbi
partendo, facendo dei viaggi esotici,
cercando risposte di qua e di là.
Io mi faccio un po' ispirare
da questa loro ricerca di sé stessi.
A mio modo,
nel senso che non vado
da nessuna parte, resto qua.
Però, in un certo senso, decido
che anch'io voglio prendere
in mano la mia vita.
Voglio fare qualcosa che mi piace.
In quel momento, due cose mi interessano.
Decido che non voglio fare l'università:
voglio navigare, voglio scoprire il mondo.
Io voglio vedere cose, voglio -
voglio saziare quella voglia
che avevo da diciottenne,
di scoprire appunto
quello che ci circonda.
Fatto sta che devo spiegarlo
ai miei genitori,
che non hanno la stessa mia idea.
Mio padre fa una cosa
veramente molto intelligente,
mi porta nell'unica università al mondo
che mescola la fisica con la vela:
Ingegneria Nautica.
È a La Spezia.
Non è il posto
più affascinante che ci sia,
per uno che ha 19 anni, e ha vissuto
tutta la propria vita a Milano.
In più ,questa università
è su un colle, sopra la città,
davanti al Golfo dei Poeti.
È un posto magnifico, è perfetto.
Mio padre mi dice: Vedi? È perfetta!
In effetti, non ho il coraggio di dire
che io l'università non la voglio fare.
Quindi, la mia carriera universitaria
inizia così.
È sicuramente diversa al liceo,
nel senso che ci sono cose
che mi interessano di più.
Però, comunque, ci sono
ancora tantissime cose
che mi incatenano, che trovo che non -
non ho ancora trovato il posto
dove mi riesco a esprimere come vorrei.
Ci sono esami, professori annoiati,
corsi che non mi interessano.
Insomma, non è diversissimo dal liceo.
L'unica cosa, effettivamente,
a cui penso con molta serenità,
quando ci penso,
sono le regate, sono i momenti
che passo in mare.
E quindi, io sono affamato
di queste esperienze,
le cerco disperatamente.
Faccio qualsiasi cosa
per avere un'opportunità
di salire in barca,
perché nella mia famiglia
nessuno va in barca.
Per loro un bompresso, una trozza,
è un insulto, come a voi
in questo momento.
Quindi devo cercare un modo
per saziare questa fame che ho.
La vela, in questi anni,
diventa una passione,
ma anche un po' un'angoscia.
Perché mi ripeto in continuazione:
Come faccio a diventare un navigatore?
Oggi l'ho capito, e ci sono
secondo me tre metodi.
Il primo.
All'epoca, nessuno me lo ha spiegato.
Il primo, la classica:
inizi da bambino, i genitori sanno
cosa sono le trozze e bompressi.
Vai sugli optimist,
che sono delle barche
a forma di vaschetta da bagno.
Poi, se sei bravo,
passi alle classi olimpiche.
Se sei bravo, passi
ai circuiti professionistici.
E così via.
Fatto sta che a 20 anni su un optimist
non ci entravo neanche a calci,
sarei affondato.
Quindi, quel metodo lì
per me non può funzionare.
Dopodiché, c'è la vacanziera:
non so perché l'ho chiamata così,
anche perché in realtà
è quella dove lavori più di tutti.
Nel senso che ti imbarchi come marinaio
e porti in giro
i proprietari delle barche,
nel senso che li aiuti a navigare.
Loro lo fanno due settimane all'anno,
tu invece sogni di fare
il navigatore, quindi -
c'è un po' un'incomprensione,
finisci più a sgorgare gabinetti,
a servire prosecco,
più che a diventare navigatore.
(Risate)
Quindi rimane di base,
sempre, questa diversità.
Siamo lì per fare cose diverse.
E poi c'è l'ultima: il navigatore.
Anche questa ha i suoi contro,
però è quella che mi interessa di più.
Nel senso che devi trovare dei fondi,
perché comunque per andare in barca
servono un sacco di soldi.
Devi trovare dei fondi,
e anche un progetto.
Io non ho né il progetto né i fondi.
Non sapevo neanche
che esistesse, questo metodo.
Fatto sta che a 20 anni
(Applausi)
ho moltissime difficoltà
a capire, effettivamente,
come togliermi quest'angoscia:
"Come faccio a diventare un navigatore?"
Sull'optimist non ci sono potuto andare,
comunque spesso ero
uno dei più giovani a bordo.
Perché poi, a un certo punto,
la vela invece diventa
uno sport per vecchi.
E quindi, finisco sempre
a lavare le sentine,
e la mia fame di conoscenza si ferma
a come pulire bene una barca.
Non è decisamente quello che cerco,
ma ancora una volta,
non so bene che cosa sto cercando.
Tuttavia, c'è una cosa
che mi dà grande fiducia,
in questa mia personalissima
ricerca della felicità.
Ogni cosa che mi passa a tiro
io mi ci butto sopra, la faccio,
poi vediamo come va.
Ed è un metodo che a un certo punto
qualche frutto l'ha portato.
Avete capito che dell'università
non ho parlato moltissimo,
perché in effetti diventa
un'attività accessoria.
Però, comunque, a La Spezia
trovo il mio mondo:
È incredibile, ma trovo il mio mondo,
perché è una città
che gira attorno al porto.
Se per me c'è una possibilità
di diventare un marinaio,
Ambrogio, che è nato a Porta Genova,
è a La Spezia.
Un giorno un amico,
un altro appassionato come me di vela,
mi fa vedere un video su YouTube.
Si chiama la Mini Transat.
Io mi innamoro follemente.
La Mini Transat è la traversata
dell'Oceano Atlantico,
che si fa ogni due mesi,
dove si sfidano 90 tra velisti e veliste
sulle barche di sei metri e mezzo.
Per me è perfetto:
finalmente ho trovato il progetto,
quella cosa che effettivamente
mi farà svegliare la mattina
con qualcosa che voglio affrontare,
a cui voglio arrivare.
Insomma, il progetto.
In più, sento
che è il modo perfetto per me
per finire la gavetta.
Un giorno un amico mi ha spiegato
cos'era la gavetta.
La gavetta finisce quando inizi
a fare cose che non sai fare.
E io, quella cosa lì,
non avevo idea di come farla.
Arriva il momento in cui devo spiegare
alle persone vicine a me, effettivamente,
che cos'è il navigatore,
perché lo voglio fare,
cos'è la Mini Transat.
Quando lo dico a mia madre,
mi chiede effettivamente:
Perché non ti droghi come tutti gli altri?
(Risate)
Poi arriva a sperare
che gli oceani si asciughino.
(Applausi)
Però la più crudele
rimane la mia coinquilina,
che quando glielo racconto ride.
Fatto sta che in un certo senso
hanno ragione anche loro;
ma a me, in quel momento lì,
sembra perfetto.
In più, è l'unica cosa che posso fare,
perché quando sei con quell'energia lì,
non guardi a tutti i problemi
che potresti incontrare.
C'è un grande problema:
le barche, come ho detto, costano.
Ma a un certo punto,
i pianeti si allineano.
Io appunto ho 20 anni,
ho lavorato il più possibile sulle barche,
non tanto per i soldi,
ma perché avevo fame di conoscenza,
di scoprire tutto quello
che riguardava le barche.
Fatto sta che ho pochi soldi;
però ho tempo, perché all'università
gliene do un po' meno.
Ma ho una voglia incredibile,
ho un'energia straripante.
Fatto sta che a un certo punto
trovo la barca dei miei sogni,
sul mercatino online.
È un relitto.
È un relitto, e io passo
sei mesi a restaurarla.
A un certo punto, la metto
finalmente in acqua.
Questa è stata la mia prima barca
con cui ho iniziato a fare le regate.
Tutti i carpentieri
di questo cantiere a La Spezia,
sono abituati a lavorare
su barche di lusso e yacht di lusso.
Quindi, questa barca qua
era chiaramente un'eccezione.
io e la barca eravamo un'eccezione.
Lavoravo su una delle barche,
degli yacht di lusso;
il catamarano, che è
là dietro, tra l'altro.
Mettevo la mia barca in mezzo a due scafi,
per avere un posto dove poter lavorare.
Effettivamente, tutti i carpentieri
ovviamente mi chiedevano: ma come va?
E tutti si aspettavano
un bel mugugno, bello corposo.
Io invece rispondevo sempre:
"Alla grande!"
A quel punto abbiamo capito:
altro problema risolto.
Abbiamo chiamato la barca "Alla grande".
In quel momento lì sono molto contento.
Sono tutto contento, direbbe qualcuno.
Fatto sta che, 10 secondi dopo,
mi rendo conto che effettivamente
ho messo tutti i miei risparmi,
tutta l'energia che avevo,
tutto quello che ero in grado
di produrre in quell'istante,
in una cosa che non sapevo
se ero in grado di fare.
E quindi c'è solo un modo
per scoprirlo: farlo.
Era un po' il metodo
che avevo applicato fino a lì.
Quindi, nel 2016 faccio la prima regata
in solitario a Genova, la vinco.
Faccio la mia prima regata in oceano:
io non ho mai fatto un miglio in oceano.
Faccio dalla Francia
alle Azzorre, e ritorno.
Le Azzorre sono isole del Portogallo
in mezzo all'oceano.
Faccio secondo, vinco la tappa di ritorno.
Insomma, dei risultati
assolutamente insperati,
che mi gasano tantissimo,
ma mi danno anche molto peso
per la Mini Transat,
che era comunque l'obiettivo
per cui mi stavo preparando.
Fatto sta che quindi
non ci arrivo preparato:
per me bastava la motivazione
per fare quello che stavo facendo.
E invece, effettivamente,
l'oceano e la competizione
mi insegnano che mancavano altre cose,
mancava il lavoro meticoloso.
Fallisco clamorosamente
quella Mini Transat:
finisco quarantaduesimo.
Ma per me è un trauma,
nel senso che mi sento come mutilato,
perché ero partito
per fare una competizione
e invece mi ritrovo a fare una crociera.
Non avevo passato tre anni della mia vita,
tutte le cose che avevo,
per fare quel viaggetto.
Perché per me è esattamente
la competizione,
il mezzo con cui mi spingo oltre i limiti.
Ma soprattutto, è lo strumento che uso
per capire il mondo complicatissimo
della navigazione oceanica.
Come evolve una nuvola?
Come cambia il vento?
Come posso sfruttare a mio vantaggio
le correnti, le onde?
Un'infinità di argomenti,
tutti complessi e in continua evoluzione.
La vela secondo me è talmente complicata,
soprattutto quando
l'ho approcciata all'inizio,
che sembrava uno sport
a che fare con la magia.
Nel senso che devi sviluppare
una sensibilità
che è più vicina alla stregoneria
che alla tecnica pura.
Immaginatevi di dover avere a che fare
con delle forze invisibili.
Una barca la vediamo che si muove,
avanza, sbanda in tutti i modi,
maa vederlo da fuori
non si capisce, non si sente perché.
Bisogna sviluppare una sensibilità
per cui, quando si è sulla barca
si capiscono queste forze
invisibili attorno.
Una specie di sciamano.
E in più, la barca
è una cosa complicatissima.
Un aereo, ad esempio,
vola in un fluido con cinque ali.
Sembra una cosa complicata,
ci fa impressione: ma com'è possibile?
Una barca galleggia tra due fluidi
che sono un po' in lotta tra di loro,
che sono le onde,
e in più abbiamo tre ali in acqua,
tre ali in aria,
tutte in equilibrio tra di loro.
Lo stregone deve fare questo,
deve riuscire a capire
qual è il miglior equilibrio possibile,
tra gli infiniti equilibri possibili,
che fa andare la barca
più veloce possibile.
Il bello è che tra marinai,
tra navigatori diversi,
a volte si arriva agli stessi risultati,
quindi a velocità molto simili,
ma con approcci completamente diversi.
Un altro tema che si avvicina
più alla stregoneria che alla scienza
sono le previsioni.
Una cosa fondamentale,
per vincere la regata oceanica,
sono le previsioni del tempo.
Non fra un'ora,
non domani, non dopodomani,
ma è importante sapere
in una traversata atlantica
l'intensità e la direzione del vento
che ci sarà tra una settimana.
A questo punto capisco
che ho bisogno almeno di un altro biennio
per fare un'altra Mini Transat:
ci sono troppe cose da capire.
Quella Mini Transat che ho fatto
senza competizione,
mi sono rimaste
tutte queste cose di traverso.
Voglio scoprirne di più:
quindi mi trasferisco in Bretagna,
posto dove tutti i navigatori
a un certo punto si formano,
in un modo o nell'altro,
e inizio a interagire
con le famose "forze invisibili".
Fatto sta che nel biennio 2018-2019
divento uno stregone:
sono il più veloce di tutti,
e sono quello che prevede
il futuro meglio di tutti.
In questo biennio vinco 10 regate
sulle 13 alle quali partecipo.
Nel 2019 divento il primo italiano
a vincere la Mini Transat.
Dopo questa esperienza, sono sicuro:
io non abbandonerò mai
la competizione come strumento.
Per me è il motore che mi spinge veramente
a studiare, a migliorarmi,
a confrontarmi con gli altri,
perché ho cercato di spiegarvelo.
La vela per me è uno sport
talmente complicato,
il mare è talmente grande,
che senza il confronto,
senza la competizione con gli altri,
non la capisco.
Ma c'è un'altra cosa che non lascerò mai,
che è la natura selvaggia
che mi ha rapito.
Negli incontri che ho avuto
con questo, in solitario,
li ha resi ancora più potenti.
Tanto da emozionarsi nel guardare,
per un pomeriggio intero,
una nuvola sciogliersi, evolversi.
Tanto da mettersi a piangere
guardando questo fenomeno così semplice,
che a terra, voglio dire,
non ci accorgiamo neanche
se ci sono le nuvole o meno.
Ho capito che stare bene
con sé stessi per me è la base.
Sicuramente è importante
quello a cui si arriva,
ma è ancora più importante
il cammino che uno cerca di fare
per cercare di essere
quello che vuole nella vita.
Io mi sento bene a terra,
non sono finito in mare come fuga.
Mi sento, insomma -
mi piace la società.
Ma gli elementi che si conoscono
in un elemento selvaggio come la natura,
ti mettono in difficoltà all'inizio,
ma a me hanno fatto sentire
quasi selvaggio.
In un certo senso,
ti tolgono tutti i problemi da umani,
che alla fine sono i più complicati,
quindi ti senti più un animale
che un essere umano,
dopo che passi tanto tempo
immerso con gli elementi.
Per me,
gli urli di gioia
che provavo surfando le onde
durante gli alisei portoghesi,
sono simili ai salti dei delfini,
agli spruzzi delle balene,
o ancora alla tecnica meravigliosa
che hanno alcuni uccelli marini,
che sfruttano per cercare
di risalire controvento,
sfruttando le onde.
Ebbene, il miscuglio
tra competizione e natura selvaggia
mi ha dato la possibilità
di confrontarmi appunto con l'oceano.
Nel senso che io sento
che ho vissuto l'oceano
con la naturalezza
delle bestie che lo abitano.
Secondo me, per fare queste cose
ci servono due cose:
una è l'amore, e l'altra è il coraggio.
Sull'amore non ho delle idee
ancora molto chiare;
però sul coraggio sì.
Mi piace farlo con una citazione
di qualcuno che sapeva benissimo
cosa fosse il coraggio.
"L'importante non è stabilire
se uno ha paura o meno;
è saper convivere con la propria paura,
e non farsi condizionare dalla stessa.
Ecco, il coraggio è questo,
altrimenti non è più coraggio,
ma incoscienza."
Grazie.
(Applausi)